hey okay there are some people out there
cool so welcome thanks for coming to my
session here on securing web apps and
api's for asp net core to 2 and 3.0 my
name is Brock Allen I call myself an
application security architect I guess I
do consulting for company called
Alliance and I basically help my
customers with their Identity and Access
Control so basically that means you know
figuring out how to get users
authenticated managing passwords doing
multi-factor authentication very often
single sign-on you know apps calling API
securely and authorization and a lot of
that revolves around a protocol called
Open ID Connect and off to and so as
part of that I actually work on an open
source project called identity server I
do some other open source projects as
well but identity servers probably the
best-known I've been doing you know
security for a long time and you know
asp.net and dotnet for for even longer
and so you know kind of speaking of the
good old days right how many of you have
been around long enough to remember what
this is anyone okay the folks with gray
hair or no hair yeah absolutely
okay so curious question how many of
these settings actually work I'll give
you a hint
none works okay well forms
authentication that worked right a lot
of people who build asp.net apps and use
this cookie based approach with
forms-based authentication that would
work Windows authentication worked that
was basically saying you know do
whatever I is does not mainly was
because you were looking to do Windows
authentication you know for your users
because they were an Active Directory
but when dotnet 1.0 was being released
they were trying to ship a product
called passport which is actually
different than whatever the new product
in the last year or so called passport
is I've been around long enough when
they start recycling product names to
something totally different it's makes
me so old I guess anyway password was
something that everybody flipped out
they didn't want and it was a product
that was cut but Microsoft didn't update
the enum so it just hung around and it
would just never did anything okay they
actually tried to do
this again when I think it was 4.5 was
shipped of asp.net and they tried to do
a new federated authentication model and
so that product also didn't ship but
they forgot to update the enum okay so
anyway don't choose federated or
Passport they're they're not gonna work
so the point of this talk is to
basically talk about modern applications
right the kind of apps we're building
are very different than they were back
in the asp.net days and what we're
looking to do is figure out how to well
really this talk is for people who are
potentially new to asp.net core or maybe
you've been a Espina using ASP net core
but you haven't like really looked into
the security features and it's meant to
give you an overview of the features in
this framework to basically be able to
architect these modern style
applications so the modern types of apps
that we're building we're building a lot
of back-end web api's right the
assumption that those are basically HTTP
based api's and then we're building a
lot of front ends that are then calling
the backends the types of front ends
were building though are actually quite
a few right we're building your
traditional server-side web app or I
think of MVC right that might be calling
an API but of course you have a user
using it and you want to do
authentication and and things like that
so there's that type of app we also have
JavaScript browser-based applications
you know spas using angular react or
whatever and those of course also want
to call API securely we're building
mobile and native apps to write either
your iOS or Android app or even the
desktop app that you might install onto
Windows or Mac and those also want to
you know authenticate a user call it Web
API and then also have like
server-to-server types of scenarios
where you want to call API securely but
there's no user using the app so that's
kind of the point of this session is to
show you what is available in asp net
core to secure this type of architecture
okay and so here's the the list of
things we're gonna look at and of course
to get started it makes sense to start
at the starting point which is the
hosting layer so asp.net core when it
was first ship came with a web server
called kestrel and the whole
architecture was that an asp net core
application when it loaded was just a
console app but it had embedded inside
of it this web server called
Estoril and so when 1.0 of asp net court
was was released they basically said
kestrel is not approved to run publicly
on the internet okay what that meant is
in your architecture you had this think
of reverse proxy in front of it so you
had to stick iis or apache or nginx in
front of your asp.net app and the intent
there was because apache and all those
other web servers were basically
battle-hardened right
they were basically you know well tested
and very mature in dealing with you know
the vicious Internet as it were okay and
then you basically would reverse proxy
back to your actual console apps on the
top right there when 2.0 of asp net core
came out they certified kestrel to run
publicly on the internet so they
actually did a whole bunch of
penetration testing they found bugs and
they fix them and they basically you
know figured out that okay great we
think we've run this through enough
tests and we we know how it all works
well enough that we will support this if
you want to stick this on your edge okay
personally I'm not sure I would do that
yet okay it's still kind of a new web
server so at least for me being a little
bit more comfortable you know wanting to
have a lot of layers of security in
there I probably still would advise the
reverse proxy approach even though it's
officially supported okay but in terms
of what the modern features are in
kestrel to be an edge server you
absolutely have to support HTTPS so
that's absolutely supported in Kestrel
you can do you know sort of the the
static based certificate mapping you
know host mapping to certificate or it
even supports the more dynamic server
name indication which is where you can
set up like a wild-card cert and you're
you're you know HTTP host could listen
for multiple domains it's nice the other
nice thing about Kestrel is that during
development you can actually use HTTP
during development they have some nice
tooling around that to do you know like
localhost but HTTP so it's good to get
in the habit of you know testing with
HTTP because there are things you miss
during development that you kind of only
find out about once you push to well
hopefully not production but at least
you know QA and testing if you do want
to run kestrel on the edge
and there are a bunch of default
settings with how it deals with incoming
you know network traffic from a security
standpoint but you need to be aware that
these things are configurable and you
may have to depending on what your app
is doing you know get familiar with some
of the low-level configuration settings
like you know the number of inbound
requests that can be accepted what the
request queue is going to be what the
timeout is going to be like when bytes
are being sent in
you know if the bytes are being sent in
too slow that might be an attack and so
you need to know what your cutoff limit
is going to be and when bytes are being
sent out or they not being read fast
enough and all these like little
low-level kind of kind of like what a
network admin might you know be thinking
about so anyway that's the thing is if
you are taking on this responsibility of
running on the edge be prepared to get
really really familiar with the stuff
okay
okay moving along in the stack then is
once you have your console app up and
running in asp net core you're gonna be
running in you know loading in asp.net
core and running in castro which it
opens up here you know in-memory web
server listening on some socket the hope
architecture that nav asp net core is it
when requests come in it invokes this
middleware pipeline in the middleware
pipeline is basically the component
model of processing requests in asp.net
core middlewares like the the reusable
component that might do logging or
exception handling or you know serving
up static files or security remind you
okay also MVC or application frameworks
like MVC are typically packaged up into
middleware and so the order of this
pipeline is very important because
that's the order that your code will run
and processing the requests so since MVC
very often is going to be rendering the
response you kind of put that at the end
of the pipeline so that when requests
come in your middleware upfront get to
do their you know whatever job that
they're doing to you know build up
whatever your web server is doing the
other big thing about asp net core is
the whole service architecture with
dependency injection so any services
that are needed during the request
processing are you know configured in
the DI container okay so you build this
middle where you put the middleware in
that you need you put the services in di
that you need
and you know you're up and running when
it comes to security then most of the
features of security from asp net core
are in the di container there has
services that are available as your you
know request is being processed there
are a couple of middlewares one
middleware is for authentication and
there's another middleware for cores but
in terms of most of the functionality
it's mainly provided out of services so
in terms of the services the first one
that actually I think most people
probably put it this way it's not a very
visible feature in asp.net core so it's
something though it's one of those
things that you maybe find out about
when you do go to production because it
didn't like show up during a local
testing and that's something called data
protection okay so in terms of sort of
going back in the Wayback Machine again
do you guys remember this from asp.net
the old machine key element what was it
for
say again to encrypt my web config no
but it is to encrypt something
yeah and crypt cookies okay so data
protection was a feature of the old
asp.net or classic asp.net I guess as we
call it now and so basically your web
application will be generating values
that are gonna leave your web server
okay and then later on that value it's
going to be sent back into your web
server and when it comes back in you
want to make sure that nobody's changed
it or modified it or tampered with it so
data protection was a general feature
the basically allowed you to pass a
value in and you got back and encrypted
and a digitally signed blob a version of
that value and then you could send it
out and that's a perfect thing for a
cookie right because when you send a
cookie to the browser right if it says
roll admin you don't want the user
changing that string in the cookie okay
so wanted to send back in data
protection could you know validate the
value and decrypt I mean you get back to
the original value okay so of course
that involves cryptography and
cryptography requires key material and
that's what that key material is so this
is now gone in asp.net core because we
were all doing this wrong okay basically
people will go to Google to figure out
what keys they should put in here that's
not a good idea
right you talking Mikey material should
be private very often
well actually where's this file located
this is the web.config file right that's
in the root of your application
directory so when requests come in like
def file is just sitting there along
with the rest of the application code so
if you have bugs in your app maybe
somehow a vulnerability that would read
your config file this would spit it out
to the end-user right there's a nice
little Google search down here right so
you might you know somehow leak this key
also people accidentally check this into
their source code repository right and
you know shows up on github okay so this
is just generally a bad idea so data
protection does exist in asp.net core
but it's completely reaaargh attacted to
solve some of these problems that we've
had so the first one i think is more
important which is the second bullet is
that the keys are automatically
generated for you you don't have to know
anything about the crypto algorithm or
how to generate the key it's just
dynamically generated for you and then
that key is used to do the you know
protecting of cookies and other things
okay now the other thing is that the
keys should be stored outside the
application directory so you have a few
options about where you store this but
this is the thing that most people don't
or aren't aware of is that you actually
have to participate in this you have to
be you know think about this realize
that you are responsible for thinking
about where to put these all right the
reason that that's important is because
in a you know load-balanced web form
environment the two different servers
have to have access to the same keys so
that they can read and decrypt each
other's cookies okay now if you're
running an azure magic happens right it
just works
okay but if you're not running an azure
you're doing your own hosting then you
need to explicitly configure this to
some shared location that both or all of
your web servers has that have access to
so you know there's some implementations
for like Redis and the database and
other things like that but basically
this is something a lot of people don't
see in development then you push to
production load balance servers your
cookies don't work okay or at least they
work half the time when you go to the
right machine but not the other machine
so I have a demo here
so what I have is just a pretty simple
asp net core application here's my
startup code and here is the
configuration for data protection and
it's just showing you how you can add in
data protection when you're setting up
data protection you can give your
application a name what this does is the
data protection key is like a master key
and then they derive a key that is
private to your app and that name
affects that that's sort of private key
and then what we're basically doing is
saying okay I want to persist these keys
to the file system and don't do this
because I'm putting it in my application
directory but this is where kind of you
would say Oh put it in this folder you
know so on the server somewhere
Microsoft basically is expecting you to
put in a UNC path if you're doing your
own you know multiple server deployment
kind of thing so you would put it in the
network share for example now if you
don't want to set up a network share
then you can implement this interface
called I XML repository that is the
actual interface that reads and writes
from the store and then you can go stick
the thing into a database or you know
Redis cache or whatever else you want to
do okay the one got you about this is
though when you do write these out to
the filesystem or to the Redis cash or
to the database then the keys will be in
plain text so anybody else who have
access to that network share or whatever
can you know read those keys so there's
one last thing you typically have to do
which is you have to think about how to
encrypt the keys that are at rest and so
Microsoft has a few features for this
one is this was actually not going to
work in a load-balanced environment but
DP API is a window specific way to do
protection of the of the of the keys but
it's you know windows specific for the
current user so this is not really gonna
work in your load-balanced environment
the other thing they have you do is
protect keys with certificate and what
you do is you'd pop in an x.509
certificate here and then that's what
you end up doing is you take a
certificate that has the private key
that's gonna protect all your other keys
and that's what you you distribute to
all those servers in your web form so
now this certificate
kind of becomes a replacement for this
thing that you used to have or
synchronize across all the machines in
your web form
okay okay so I'll leave that back here
so what I'm gonna do is I'm gonna run
this and again I'm storing this in the
current directory and I know you can't
see it it's not here there's there's no
text file with this key material so what
I'm gonna do is run this and what we
should see is when this app starts up
there we go this key got created so if
we pop this open we'll see that this is
a the actual key it's stored inside of
this XML file this XML file has
information about when the key was
created right when it should be
activated when it should be expired okay
that's actually an interesting feature
of this is that the key that it creates
actually has an expiration so after 90
days by default a new key gets created
that's kinda like good key hygiene you
do key rolling okay so it's kind of nice
you'll see then multiple keys over you
know months and months and months start
to accumulate here and then here's the
actual key material and because it's on
plaintext we don't want to visible to
everybody so we've actually then done
further encryption of it in this case
with DEP API again that won't work
across servers you'd use a certificate
approach so I'm gonna run this
application no actually I'm already
running and the job of this application
is actually to use the data protection
API so what I'm gonna do is type in you
know
hello NDC okay and I've now encrypted
that value so if you had your
application you had some value you
wanted to send as a query string to
another page in your app or you had a
you're building a wizard where you're
building upstate and doing like post
backs cross multiple steps of a wizard
type of thing and you wanted some data
to persist across those but you made it
wanted to make sure nobody messed with
it this is exactly what you'd use okay
now what I'm gonna do just to show you
that this key material is important I
shut down my server
I'm gonna go delete the key file okay
which I should here we go close that I'm
gonna rerun my server okay a new key got
created so there's a new key there and
now if I try to unprotect the same value
it fails right because the key that was
used to protect is not now the same key
to deep unprotect therefore crypto fails
right and you get an exception
that the unprotected layer fails okay
just to show you that there in fact is
you know ciphertext and you know other
looking keyring looking crypto things
alright so anyway that's the point of
that okay questions about that right so
the question is about the decree okie
rollin and then what if I what if I
create a cookie that's protected with
the first key and then at that moment a
second key gets created will that
cookies still unprotect and so the key
rolling is for new protections but all
the prior keys are still are possible in
the keyring four unpretentious so they
keep around the old ones so that's
actually a good point is that if you are
gonna build your own database or leave
this on the filesystem keep the old ones
right don't throw those away or rather
the ones that you can throw away or the
ones that you are guaranteed that you
don't have any still outstanding
unprotected data right keys from two
years ago probably good to throw away
okay cool that's what the key file looks
like this key data protection feature is
used a couple actually several different
areas in asp.net core it's used in the
cookie stuff that we just talked about
so when you are using an authentication
cookie right that's very important
cookie that needs to be data protected
if you're using the anti forgery feature
in asp net core which pretty much
anybody with a postback is that is using
the data protection to derive that if
you're using Open ID Connect or Google
logins or anything else you're making
round trips out of your app over to
Google and then back and there's data
that's roundtrip this part of that that
needs to be protected as well if you're
using the temp data feature in MVC where
you can put like a little message in a
temp data and then a redirect to the
next page and read out the temp data
that is get that gets put into a cookie
and it also needs to be protected you
know basically for integrity checks and
as I mention here in my little demo I
actually didn't show you the code it
probably should have but there you can
use this yourself directly so you inject
into your controller constructor
arguments the data protection provider
you create a protector and then you can
use the protected
that's okay pretty easy to use yes
question you're passing the what page to
page an ID okay so well I mean so
whatever the data is let's not focus on
an ID but whatever the data might be you
actually protect the data and it gives
you back that gobbledygook I showed you
in the demo and the gobbledygook is what
you send over to the next page
so the gobbledygook has the original
value and the checksum all lumped into
one makes sense okay now you saw it was
big right that's the cost of doing the
you know the encryption and the digital
signature okay but you have integrity so
that's pretty darn important okay
the next service that we need to talk
about in ASP that of course the
authentication service this is basically
the infrastructure that allows a user to
log into your system and so there are
actually lots of different options here
lots of features that Microsoft provides
one is obviously local authentication so
we user can just walk up to your app
enter a username and password and get
logged in they also have support for
social logins so Facebook and Twitter
and that kind of thing Microsoft only
provides four out of the box social
logins but there is a contributor that
has about fifty more so Yahoo github
battlenet right if you want to log in
with your Warcraft account untappd if
you do the beer-drinking app right and
you need to use that to log in all that
all the important ones are there okay so
basically use social logins to get into
your app Microsoft also provides more
enterprise grade authentication support
using the standards like Open ID Connect
and WS Federation so that's actually
really important with enterprises or
even your own you know act to Azure
Active Directory logins where you want
to be able to you know send the user up
there to login and then they come back
to your app with their identity from
that identity provider sam'l 2 P is
another very popular not so much in the
Microsoft bit space but in more in the
Java space protocol it is not supported
by Microsoft but there is another
open-source project out there
by a guy named Anders able from
sustained stress sustained sis he builds
this sam'l provider that fits right into
a SPI net core so that's actually you
know great easy to use and it works well
there's also support for JSON web tokens
that's basically if you're gonna be
doing API security with a token so
there's support that Microsoft has for
that as well okay and then no matter how
you're gonna log in at least with one of
the interactive options with a user you
need to manage the authentication
session for that user
which is basically backed by a cookie so
there is a cookie you know component
that will help you manage that okay the
way the authentication system works in
asp net core is that there are is a
service in the DI container and then
what you do is you register handlers
which are like there's like a micro
framework so there are these handlers
that will do the specific ones that you
want so there's a handler for google
there's a handler for facebook there's a
handler for cookies and so on and so
forth so what an example of setting up
an application would look like is that
in your di configuration when configure
services you would call a doll
indication that adds the general
authentication services you then add
cookies Google and open ID connect
because those are the particular
handlers that this application wants to
use so you want to do session management
with cookies and you want to allow the
user to go to Google login and you want
to allow the user to go to some open ID
connect provider to login okay whenever
you register these handlers you give
them a name and that's that scheme
that's associated with each one that's
so that in your application when you
want to talk to one of these guys you
talk to them via than the scheme name
okay it turns out you actually don't
talk to them directly you're required to
go through this service called the
authentication service so this is like
an Orchestrator or an abstraction over
those handlers and it provides you a
sort of a consistent API for the types
of things you would want to communicate
to the handlers okay
so the first method is something called
authenticate async this basically says I
want to read the incoming request and
know who the user is
okay now when you call this this
basically says I want to read the
request so that's perfect for a cookie
right imagine every single request
coming in you're gonna read the cookie
now you don't want to write that code
and every single one of your action
methods or whatever so a very typical
pattern is you would put a piece of
middleware in the pipeline to sit in
front of the rest your app to do that
and that's exactly what the
authentication middleware does it's its
sole purpose in life well for the most
part but it's its primary purpose is to
crawl this authenticate method up here
and what it does is it calls
authenticate now there's a parameter
called scheme and it basically says hey
I want to read the request because I
want one of these handlers to trigger
now we know that it's really the cookie
that we want to read on every request so
I didn't use a any kind of configuration
down here in the user authentication so
which of the three handlers runs right
well you can pass null for the scheme
and if you do what you're saying is you
would like
whichever one you've marked as the
default to run so basically now on every
single request use authentication calls
the authenticate method passing a null
scheme the null scheme means oh use
cookies we go to the cookie handler we
let hit to his job it reads the cookie
if the cookie produces a valid user then
the authentication middleware sets the
user on the HTTP context so now the rest
of the requests in the pipeline has a
user object okay if there was a cookie
and it validated because of data
protection all right the other methods
use all here sign-in and sign-out are
the two methods for doing off nth
occation session management sign-in
basically says create a cookie sign out
says delete the cookie very simple right
so if you're building a login page well
after you've validated a password you'll
call sign-in if the user clicks sign out
you'll call sign out
challenge is the method that says hey
you know what the users anonymous I need
to redirect them to go login okay so the
scheme is a very important parameter
here because what it does is it
identifies oh do I want to send them to
Google or Facebook or open ID Connect or
what
so that challenge method basically kind
of lets you you know indicate which one
to trigger if you happen to trigger
cookies
well cookies is your session management
but it also kind of has the notion of
saying oh I need to go get the user
logged in but the assumption is that's a
local login so you would need to
configure what you know local you are or
what path in your app is gonna have your
your login page
okay and forbid is the last method and
that basically says hey you know I know
who the user is they're just not allowed
to be here okay
and so forbid generally triggers like an
error page or an access denied page
there are a bunch of extension methods
on the HTTP context to wrap that up to
make it more convenient so I'll just
leave those there and here's an example
of an application that is just doing
cookies for example so the idea is that
maybe I'm just doing local logins so
I've configured authentication the
scheme is the default scheme is cookies
I only have a cookie authentication
Handler and notice I'm configuring like
the login path so when we call challenge
on cookies that will redirect the user
to the local login then you can
configure the aspects of the cookie like
the name of the cookie how long you want
it to be does it slide does it have the
same site flag and then how do you talk
to the cookie handler to actually issue
the cookie or you know get rid of the
cookie well this is what something like
your your login page might have so once
the user has entered a username and
password what we will do is look them up
in the database validate the password
okay
how we do that well again that's up to
you I'm going to talk about asp.net
identity in a minute which is the
Microsoft library for doing that but
actually this is a very important
distinction that library identity is how
they call it or asp.net identity that's
unrelated actually what I'm showing you
here right I mean you probably used them
together but strictly speaking you don't
have to use that this is the code it
takes to just get a user logged in
regardless of where you keep their
password so what we do is we create a
list of claims this is modeling the
information about the user that we care
about so sub is usually the users unique
ID subject identifier and then we also
say oh I know
you know it's Bob so I'll set the name
claim
and we create a claims identity class
and then down here at the sign-in call
we pass that in and those claims
basically become the information that's
written out to the cookie so now our
cookie contains the users unique ID one
two three and their display name Bob so
you can you know show it later so your
login page has to decide what claims you
want to basically serialize into the
cookie now when you issue a cookie with
asp.net core the authentication cookie
the cookie has the claims which is the
information about the user but it also
has this other section which is like a
dictionary and you could just put
arbitrary other you know metadata if you
want in there and so that's what this
authentication properties is is
basically you can stick whatever you
want to in this items collection that
will also get written to the cookie okay
and then you can read that out later for
whatever whatever you might need that's
actually how internally they keep track
of like the expiration right you're
supposed to expire you know the cookie
supposed to expire in 20 minutes they
actually internally use the same
dictionary the sign out method at the
bottom here is actually then what we
call to delete the cookie okay all right
good there are a few other features on
the cookie handler actually all the
handlers have this eventing model where
when sort of interesting internal
processing is occuring they'll raise an
event and so for the cookie when a
couple of interesting events are so the
the cookie comes into your application
the authenticate gets called because we
have the middle where the cookie will
read the the cookie handler will read
the cookie validate it with data
protection everything looks good and
then it will raise an event which is
called validate user right basically
gives you a hook after the cookies been
checked out to see if you actually want
to accept the cookie or accept that
request from that user gives you a
chance to maybe like look up in the
database right but cookie says it's Bob
well you look up in the database but
maybe see if Bob's really been
deactivated and you can reject this so
that the cookie is not actually trusted
there are also events around redirecting
for sign
redirecting for sign-out and so on and
so forth now one of the other things
about the cookie handler that's good to
be aware of is remember I said that we
could put claims into the cookie we can
put this arbitrary you know dictionary
with arbitrary data well that's gonna
make your cookie bigger and bigger and
bigger the more stuff you put in there
okay how big can your cookie be well it
depends that's the consult answer of
course do you have to sit the real the
real question is this do you have to
support Safari on iOS if the answer is
no then you have a lot of space in that
cookie like 16k of data okay if you have
to support Safari on iOS then you have
very very little space your entire
domain has to have less than 4 K of
cookies and it doesn't take long to get
up there ok so that's not just one
cookie that's all the cookies so Safari
on iOS we'll just start throwing away
cookies randomly and the user all sudden
will be you know like logged out okay so
how do you mitigate against that well
you can instead of serializing all those
claims and that dictionary into the
cookie proper you can actually implement
a storage mechanism that stays
server-side ok but that means you now
have to have a database that puts the
blob of data and then what gets written
to the cookie is just a you know an
identifier ok so at least it'll make the
cookie a lot smaller that's kind of cool
though actually I like that feature
because it allows server-side revocation
right let's say your admin decides hey
that user right I'm gonna kick him out
of the website well how do you go to
that users browser and delete their
cookie yeah it's not gonna happen so
what you can delete the record in the
database and now the cookie won't match
right and they will be considered
anonymous ok cool another feature then
of the authentication system is this
concept of external authentication right
being able to do a hey you know password
in your app is great but it's better if
you don't have to deal with passwords ok
so the architecture that we tend to move
towards is getting credentials out of
your app your app instead trust
something else to log the user in
usually some sort of single sign-on
server ok so you could trust something
like Google or you could trust Azure
Active Directory
you could build your own very very
common pattern okay and the basic
workflow is this when the user indicates
that they want to go login with the
external provider that's where you call
the challenge method and challenge
basically triggers whichever handler
Google Facebook Open ID Connect and it
redirects the user away from your
application okay they're gone from your
app so that's an interesting workflow
right you're used to having the user
redirect all within your app they're now
gone and you don't know when they're
coming back hopefully it'll be soon
right but you don't know so the workflow
then is that they're gone from your app
they go to Google they log in and
eventually Google redirects the user
back into your app to what's called a
redirect URI or there's a callback path
in your app and it's sort of the
dedicated landing place for the user
after Google okay or after Facebook or
whatever and your app has to continue
processing from there as if the user you
know is still in their middle of their
their login workflow usually that's all
handled by the authentication handler so
that's good but yeah okay
so here's an example of what that would
look like to use Open ID Connect
so open ID Connect is a protocol for
authentication it allows a user to go to
a different identity provider to login
and then your app can get the result of
that and your app doesn't have to
collect the credential one thing when
they come back from the external
provider though they do need to have an
authentication session in your app so
notice we still have to use cookies
because the result of the external
authentication
that's just like a one-time handshake
and as that's complete you want to keep
track of the user so the external
authentication will result in a cookie
within your application so we have to
have cookies and that we add open ID
Connect there's a bunch of coordinates
you have to configure to make that
protocol work okay and now what will
happen is you want the cookie to be read
on every request so notice we've marked
that as the default scheme okay but when
you call challenge like if you have the
authorized attribute hmm authorize is
going to trigger the default scheme we
don't want to do cookies because the
whole point of this is not to have a
local login so when you configure these
defaults you can actually have a default
that's different
for one of those five different methods
so when the internal system calls
challenge which is what the authorized
attribute does it'll instead trigger the
OID C one and that sends the user out
token ID Connect but when it comes back
and issues the sign-in method and the
sign out and the and the the reading of
every request it'll use cookies instead
so it's a nice little way to kind of mix
both together all right I have a demo
for all this I'm leading up to it I have
to show you all the parts and then I'll
show you the demo the last thing that
you might be want to be aware of is for
api's the typical approach for securing
web api is is using a token based
architecture so we typically use
something called a JWT or jot as the
pronunciation goes and basically your
web api i actually highly encourage you
to set up your web api in a separate
project just keeps it cleaner
okay now the web api project you only
have jots in your pipeline terms of
authentication and micro Microsoft
provides a you know handler for JSON web
tokens using called the job bearer
authentication handler okay so that's
how you might protect your api's so I
have a demo of this so this demo has
actually many many moving parts of a
whole bunch of things I just talked
about this so the first thing is the
startup code the startup code basically
is where we say yes I want to do cookies
right so I'm going to do local session
tracking but I want to log my users in
externally using Open ID Connect okay so
I have those configured and I show you
the default schemas cookies but the
challenge default challenge scheme is
open ID Connect like I just talked about
I have a home controller right when you
come in here yeah you can be anonymous
to come here but when I click the secure
link authorize says I need a logged in
user
so authorize internally it calls the
authentication system and it calls the
challenge method if the users not
authenticated and that's where we get
back to this where it says oh I'm
calling challenge who do i trigger
challenge on oh that guy open ID connect
ok run this and that says go elsewhere
to go login ok when this thing comes
back it issues a cookie using the
sign-in method sign-in gets called
and it triggers the default cookie and
then we'll have a cookie in our app and
then when we go to the secure page what
I'm showing you here once we finally
make it all the way back I'm showing you
the claims that are in the cookie and
I'm showing you that dictionary remember
I said the the cookie has the claims and
that dictionary of key value pairs so
let's just run this and see if this bit
works okay I hit my secure link okay I'm
in localhost 3 308 now I'm out right I'm
off in some other website which is my
identity provider that's where my users
have their credentials right so I'm
gonna log in with Alice and Alice right
the web is working today hmm that seems
slow very very bizarre hmm Google okay
okay
we're it's hosted in Azure so okay allow
then we come back alright so basically
we completed the workflow what ended up
happening is as a result of all of that
notice now I have a cookie called
cookies which happens to line up with
the name of my authentication scheme
that I was calling it here right if you
could set up name you would see the name
here and notice what's in the cookie
then is we have a bunch of claims these
are the claims that came back from the
external identity provider we have a
bunch of properties with a bunch of junk
in here as well and the thing I want to
show you is look how quickly we got
above 4k right just with that little bit
of data right so that's actually pretty
easy to get up there with you know just
a few more claims okay the other thing I
want to show you then is that this app
wants to call an API right hmm I need a
token for that right that's the the
architectural pattern these days so it
turns out that when I was request
a login from my login provider I was
also asking for access to this API and
so what handed up getting back was in
addition to all of the identity
information about the user like their
name and their email and so on and so
forth I now have this thing called an
access token and the access token if we
pop open a website called JMS pop that
access token in there notice we have
this JSON data structure that's where
the j and jot comes from it's a JSON
object that is digitally signed by the
token server and it contains claims
about my user so my subject identifier
which is the most important thing about
the user that's the users unique ID if I
go back to my login app if I go up here
yeah sub1 that is Alice's unique ID okay
so I can use that now to call an API so
what API do on a call will have another
project here called API let me run this
guy so it's another project in Visual
Studio
I go to my startup for this guy and
notice I'm then using authentication but
in this case I'm only accepting tokens
I'm accepting jot bearer tokens and it
should come from that same login
provider that my app just used to login
the user okay so now when I go back to
my app wherever it was and I call my API
I want to this is a request into my web
server the web server then has to make
another network hop to the API so it's a
server to server call from the
server-side MVC to the web api server
but an I want it to be on behalf of the
user and that's why we're using that
token so if I go into the home
controller when I call the API I can
reach in to the cookie that has the
dictionary I can ask for that access
token I create an HTTP client and I'm
setting the bearer token I'm setting
this as the authorization header when we
call to the Web API and that
authorization header is going to contain
basically wherever it went this jot
information when it shows up the web api
the web api will decode that validate it
and know who my user is so if I hit the
button here
here we go
so that basically called the web api
successfully I got the results back and
we're just echoing back what was in the
access token
so the Web API saw that the users unique
ID was one okay questions about that yep
question yep yep yeah so that there's a
little bit of history there and maybe a
little bit beyond the time we have to
talk about here to answer the question
the question is why do I have this
audience thing and this scope thing
they're actually pretty much the same
thing as long as you're validating one
of them you're good okay
come and grab me afterwards and I gave
you the history behind why we have to
it's basically because they're two
different specs and one specs is you
have to do one one spec says you have to
do the other and I'm actually using both
specs at the same time so I have to
satisfy both okay okay cool
questions other questions one other
issue with access tokens is that access
tokens expire right if you scroll down
here a little bit it's gonna say hey
your access tokens going to expire in
some amount of time usually it's about
an hour so the problem here is that now
you're calling on your MVC app over to
the Web API you're calling the API
you're calling the API it works it works
it works and then all of a sudden you
get a 401 and 401 means hey your access
tokens no good anymore you have to go
get a new access token and I think we
lost our projector here so what do you
do well we need to go and somehow get a
new access token now what I don't want
to do is redirect my user and the main
browser all the way and come back so the
protocol has something called refresh
tokens and a refresh token this way you
can programmatically go back to the
token server from your MVC app and get a
new access token okay great well you
have to write that code unfortunately
Microsoft doesn't provide anything so
what we've done here is a kind of a
nifty little sample is we have this
little addition called add automatic
token management what's happening is
this is just a
some extensibility points are taking
advantage of the extensibility points of
a cookie and what it's registering is
member has said the cookie raises events
the cookie handler we're tapping into
those events and remember the validate
method that's where the user has been
validated from the cookie right you get
to look at the claims okay before the
rest of the request goes so we're not
doing it necessarily to reject the user
but what we're doing this using this
force a hook every time the cookie comes
in I'm actually extracting the tokens
from that cookie I'm looking for my
refresh token I'm checking for the
expiration and if my expiration is you
know within near you know some soon time
right which I think we default to one
minute right yeah nope wrong one if the
there we go
yeah we're basically saying hey if we're
within one minute of expiration then
let's go
you know renew the token so we basically
go off and go back to the token server
get the results and then what we do is
we actually get the updated access token
and we update your cookie with the
results because we have to restore them
okay so I've been talking for over a
minute this access token actually
expires in one minute so I'm gonna hit
refresh here and notice the access token
should change and the Refresh token
probably should change so yeah I hit
refresh they changed that showed that
this requests coming in right triggered
that and said oh I need to go get new
one so if I hit refresh right now yeah
they're not changing but if wait long
enough again I forget what the
expiration it's I think it's two minutes
we should see it happen again
yeah there we go okay so the point is
this is illustrating the usage of the
events off of the cookie we also do this
at sign out time we're handling the sign
out time of the cookie to go and revoke
the token as well from the token server
so nice little demo kind of showing all
these little pieces all working together
in one application okay I have 15
minutes left so I got a hurry the next
feature is the authorization feature
from asp.net core so the authorization
feature is completely rewritten
in asp.net core mainly to move away the
role centric model of the prior asp.net
so you're familiar with the role based
approach where you put authorize and you
put a comma-separated list of roles
right that's very very coarse-grained
doesn't give you a lot of fine-grained
control the comma-separated list is now
your logic right if you ever that logic
in more than one place you've got to
copy that all over the place I had a
customer who had that authorized
attribute everywhere that whenever they
have a change to the logic they actually
couldn't go find it all so they actually
wrote a tool to read their entire code
base find the authorized attribute find
the role they were talking about and
then rewrite all their code out with the
new value if you're doing that
something's wrong right
so this authorization framework that's
new in asp net core is called policy
based off authorization and it's
actually quite nice because it helps
point us in the direction of of a better
pattern okay
the better pattern is basically just
giving us a level of indirection okay so
this isn't quite rocket science right
it's it's it's what we use in computer
science to solve any problem except for
performance of course is we put a level
of dreaming direction in so notice at
the bottom here I have the authorized
attribute it does not have a list of
roles it has kind of like a permission
name called manage customers that is
using the new policy system it basically
says the user has to satisfy this policy
called manage customers to get into the
method okay well where's the policy it's
not here well that's what the code on
the top left is the code on the top left
is basically creating a policy so we're
adding the authorization services to di
we are creating a policy called manage
customers and a policy is a list of
requirements the requirements are things
that the user has to satisfy to satisfy
the entire policy so there are three
requirements and the user has to satisfy
all three the first one is of course the
user has to be authenticated okay you
have to be authenticated to get in sure
you also have to have a claim called
department sales and you also have to
have a status of senior and if one of
those doesn't match or doesn't pass you
failed the policy and you get rejected
from
method okay the beauty here now is my
logic is in one place if I choose to
change the rules change about you know
who can manage customers I have one
place to do it all right I don't have to
go and search through my entire code
base for everywhere I use that role for
example also we can call this
programmatically the authorization
service is actually a service in DI so
instead of just using the attribute you
can do this programmatically so you can
do this within your code right this
actually makes your action method unit
testable if you wanted to do it this way
this also allows you to call the logic
from multiple places and imagine in your
UI you want to hide the button if you
can't manage customers but you also have
to enforce it on the post back alright
so those are two different places that
need the one chunk of logic so this
gives you the ability to do that also
policies themselves are you know unit
testable so you can actually just test
the policy and make sure that it does
what you want independent of the rest of
the application especially then if you
choose to change it in the future you
run all your unit tests against your
policy if anything breaks well you've
broken the logic the policy based system
then can get even more advanced or
sophisticated so the way this demo works
here or the way the sample works on the
slide it kind of leads you to think that
policies only work against claims that
the user has in the cookie for example
okay and that's not true
claims are meant to model the users
identity information not their
permissions okay
so the identity information is an input
into your policy sure and if your policy
can satisfy its logic by just looking at
that identity information you're good to
go but very often your authorization
logic might need other sources of data
all right the user is an input the who
that user is I need to go look up in the
database
more information to find out if they're
allowed to do something okay like I said
you don't want to put a million
permissions into your claims because
your cookie will get too big so how's
that work well the policy based system
has
to create what's called a custom handler
basically what this is is you can create
your own requirement and a requirement
is just a concept it can have some data
with it if you want or not anything at
all it doesn't really matter but the
whole point is you create this concept
of a requirement so I've created this
job level requirement you then create
the logic or the class the handler that
knows how to check that requirement and
this goes in the DI system now that this
is in the DI system at runtime when this
requirement is being executed this is
resolved from di which means this class
can resolve other things from di like
your organizational service or a DB
context or an HTTP context to call a web
api and now in this handle method where
you implement your logic you're handed
in this context that has the user so
that's the user with all their claims
from the cookie
typically and you get the requirement
object that may have some additional
data for you to you know do your logic
and then you can call out to your
database call out to your services to
help get the results that you need to
say you like the user or you don't and
if you do you call the succeeded method
and that means that this handler or this
requirement has been satisfied ok that's
the idea with this so we're putting
levels of indirection for more
testability composability things like
that ok so yeah I think that the
takeaway here if you weren't aware of
this is that claims are typically not
for permissions ok they're for identity
information and that's an input to your
authorization which maybe then goes and
looks out elsewhere for permissions ok
there's one last style and again I'll go
quickly because I'm running out of time
is that there's the next sort of level
of sophistication of this policy based
authorization is a resource based
authorization
so so far cut up to this point you're
only looking at the user to see if
they're allowed to do something well
what if it the logic is it depends on
the user what they're trying to do and
what object they're trying to do that
too ok so the typical example is Brok is
trying to delete a document ok does
Brock have the rights to delete that
document maybe maybe not
probably have to go look at the document
to find out so that's the concept of
resource based authorization same idea
you basically build a handler just like
the Priya prior one except this handler
takes in addition to the users an input
you take the the operation right what
the user is trying to do and you then
take the resource that the users trying
to operate against in this case like a
document and then you go sort it out
with whatever your logic is you say
succeed and the user can can get in and
do it okay so this is what it would look
like to invoke that against the same
authorization service that I mentioned
it's in the DI system you authorize past
the user of the document and the
operation and it says yay or nay okay oh
so another probably a topic that could
totally be a whole day on its own is
asp.net identity this is a whole other
set of services provided by Microsoft
which it has to do with managing the
database that holds your user
information and more importantly the
credentials for your user so all the
stuff about session management and
cookies and all that that's an important
piece that's the authentication piece
but if you are collecting credentials
and want to validate a username and
password you need a database for that so
that's strictly speaking with asp.net
identity is for it's really just a fancy
wrapper around the database and some
password hashing and and it does things
the right way this is something you
don't want to build on your own from
scratch so this will manage the record
and the database for your user their
password you know email for doing
password resets they have a whole
workflow for validating the email to
make sure it's really the right email
they support multi-factor authentication
so they have things for onboarding
multi-factor devices and validating
those and dealing with lost multi-factor
devices for the login workflow and helps
with brute force protection I actually
had a customer this Monday during the
workshops who is being brute force
attacked and they were like calling me
up like what's going on what do we do
and I said well you're okay because you
know none of their users got compromised
because the brute force protection was
kicking in and locking out this attempts
okay it also deals with creating a
record for your user that maps from an
external login so if you do have Google
logins or open ID connect logins when
the user shows up in your app you still
need a record for that user even though
you don't have a password so it helps
with that as well okay so again this is
the the library that you should probably
use to be managing that record further
your user in the database okay if you
are using this then there is a bridge to
then issuing your cookie right so if you
do have the login page you call this to
validate the password but then you of
course needs a cookie to be created
using the authentication system and then
that's the last piece there which is
something called the you know the the
sign-in manager for issuing cookies and
deleting cookies okay
so the last piece here in my last four
minutes is those are a lot of really
good features provided by asp.net core
to build that architecture that I had
mentioned at the beginning okay there's
actually a missing piece though right
there's lots of really good components
in there for doing like you know doing
external authentication right getting a
token back validating the token - like
with Open ID Connect and using the token
to call the API and validating a token
at the API so those components consume
tokens the thing Microsoft is missing is
something that produces tokens in other
words a token server or something that
is your single sign-on server now
Microsoft has lots of products that
doesn't do this right as your Active
Directory b2c and things like that but
there's nothing in the box that lets you
do your own okay well until asp net core
3.0 i mentioned at the beginning of the
session i work on an open source project
called identity server and it basically
allows you to build your own you know
your own single sign-on server
people use this typically in your
application architecture to set up your
own token server your own single sign-on
server to abstract all of your apps from
the details of logging in and that
includes passwords but it includes maybe
federating with a directory directory or
a business partner okay so Microsoft's
actually now going to be shipping this
in the templates in Visual Studio
so basically it's a I have a VM here
somewhere there we go
and this VM is it has the Visual Studio
20 19.1 or whatever preview so it's the
preview for asp net core 3.0 okay and
what I have done is I've done a file new
project and I did the spa template and
the spa template I went to the checkbox
or says I want authentication for my
api's that's basically been missing from
their template story all the way since
asp net core was shipped or you know
released so we've been working with
Microsoft to figure out how to have them
use our new get package and they are
building their own little abstraction
over our configuration system to kind of
give you a zero config where you can
have identity server in your project
protecting your api's issuing tokens but
with you not having to really think too
much about it okay so the way this works
is we gonna start up here's asp net
sorry that's the DB contacts for asp net
identity here's the code for asp.net
identity that's the database
you know password management stuff aha
and here is where they're adding
identity server this is just our
extension method directly from our new
get package they then are wrapping up
with this fluent API their one-liner of
configuration if you will their
configuration I believe is driven by
what's in Jason so you can let go and
set up more client apps and you know
things like that here maybe you want a
mobile app and a spa and a desktop app
or whatever so you can set those up in
here and then this project also is
hosting an API so the API that's
co-hosted with your login page that's
co-hosted with identity server wants to
you know validate tokens from that same
identity server so that's what those two
lines do there so if we run this
so this is their new bootstrap for
template I will go here to login and I
know it's kind of hard to see but if you
look up here you'll see this return URL
is connect authorize client ID redirect
URI there's some scopes in there if you
know the open ID connect to know off
protocols those terms will be familiar
so the point is under the covers there
hiding identity server and I guess
you'll just have to take my word for it
it's there okay
so then when I login with Brock one two
three come back here and I go to my
let's open up my network tab here and go
to my fetch data page notice what
happens is actually I can show you this
is that sorry wrong place this fetch
data call what it ended up doing is an
ajax call back to the web api and in the
word there is hey look at this the
authorization header there's a bearer
token and that is a JSON web token that
is coming from the identity server that
you guys almost didn't even see there
right so it looks like the old you know
asp net identity templates but under the
covers they're actually making the spa
communicate formally with the token
server that's co-hosted you get tokens
back and those tokens are being used to
call the api tokens are a great way to
call those api's because it helps you
with the cross-site request forgery
problem right you don't have to do that
your ante forgery stuff this
encapsulates both authentication and
ante forgery in one you know credential
format just other color other quick
thing here is if i remember where they
put the javascript code the other thing
they're doing is they're they're
providing this is actually the angular
template they do the same from the react
template is that they're pulling in this
javascript library which is the
open-source JavaScript library for spa's
to do open ID connect okay so they're
wrapping that up and that's you know the
all the protocol work is really
happening in that library
this template is just kind of wrapping
it up into a angular service that makes
a little easier to use okay and then
they have an interceptor for their
outbound HTTP calls and what the
Interceptor is doing is pulling in that
authorization service and in the
authorization service they're getting
the access token and then what they're
doing is they're popping in the access
token here into the authorization header
using the bearer scheme okay so what am
i it's in there it's kind of cool kind
of cool they've been this is a working
on this for a long time so it's kind of
cool to see identity server now they're
in okay so that should be are coming out
in 3.0 in addition they have other
workflows that they're going to be
supporting like server to server API
scenarios as well and in the future
they'll be expanding that more so this
is just the first step towards that okay
other that that hopefully gives you an
idea of a lot of the features in asp net
core to allow you to build secure modern
asp.net core applications thanks for
having me and by the way I have identity
server stickers up here I have a whole
bag of them for all four of you so if
you want to come grab a sticker you can
other than that thanks and enjoy the
party tonight